at this point it they've seen every kind
of volunteer imaginable go down there I
mean there have been thousands and tens
of thousands of volunteers who've gone
down to New Orleans to help rebuild and
that's all great it all needs to happen
it's all extremely important but there
have been very very few that have
actually gone to New Orleans and asked
the residents what it is that they want
you know a lot of people go down there
with great intentions and do great work
but have no interaction with the people
and kind of come down with this
mentality of I know what needs to be
done I'm going to help you and we don't
really believe in that and we believe in
solidarity and bottom-up organizing and
so we want to that's why we canvassed we
go out it's for our personal experiences
and the individual conversations but
it's to get the members of the community
to come together at community meetings
so that together they can decide what
needs to be changed what the major
issues are and then how we can further
assist them in that and a lot of the
times it's rebuilding a lot of times
it's more canvassing and you know the
the need for a gross for food and for a
school came directly from these
community meetings and so we acted on